was für eine fernsehsendung hast du die
beste die schönste die spannendste die
spektakulärste kuppel show der welt
[Musik]
der enkel von von unserem ehemaligen
finanzminister stoltenberg der war
irgendwie der absolute frauenliebling
hast du das gestorben direkt war schon
ziemlich sehr lustig er war ehrlich
selber sich selbst und der hat so ein
paar sprüche über die bekannte tv
sendung braucht die leute unterhalten
er hat alle alt ist und schon so ein
schnitzel rasanten spaß habe ich das
schön gesagt motto morelia bongiorno
tumoren lassen hier los
kommt dazu dass er so schon ziemlich
bereit war zu flirten und zu blieben auf
der insel also wenn du sie hast wer wlan
chip für dich gewesen
ach ja ich bin seit 16 jahren glücklich
also ich denke nicht mal darüber nach
[Musik]